(Originalton aus Radio) 3.05 Uhr.
Das ist dein Lieblingssender
vom Oberland.
Hier mit einem Stück ruhiger Musik
für diejenigen,
die schon oder noch wach sind.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Telefonklingeln *
Fahrdienst Spiez.
Was ist denn los?
- Ich weiss es nicht!
Spiez. Ich verstehe kein Wort.
* Stimmengewirr *
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Ich hatte eigentlich nie
so ein gutes Gefühl dabei,
dort arbeiten zu müssen.
Ich habe Mama immer wieder gefragt:
"Warum ist Papa
noch nicht zu Hause?"
* Dramatische Musik *
Otto, was ist los?
Scheisse!
Geh jetzt raus!
Jetzt raus!
Ich weiss nicht, was ich tun soll!
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass das Leute sind, die ich kenne.
Fuck!
Ich habe in meiner Bahnzeit
schon vieles erlebt,
aber das
war mit Abstand das Schlimmste.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
(Originalton aus Radio)
The Amazing Rhythm Aces singen:
"Bring einen Zug in den Himmel!"
Ich war an jenem Abend
bei meinen Eltern,
weil mein Papa immer sagte,
die Nachtschichten, die er habe,
seien sehr anstrengend.
Und dann sagte ich zu meiner Mutter,
wenn das so anstrengend sei,
würde ich bei ihr übernachten.
Dann könnten wir uns am anderen Tag
einen schönen Tag machen,
damit er schlafen könne und Ruhe
habe. Er machte sich Sorgen.
Meine Mutter sagte, er mache
nicht zum ersten Mal Nachtschicht.
Er sagte, diese Nacht
sei etwas aussergewöhnlich.
* Sanfte Musik *
Die Gruppe Lötschental
ist in Goppenstein stationiert.
Es ist eine Arbeitsgruppe,
die Gleisgruppe.
Und innerhalb der Gruppe
war der Zusammenhalt gross.
Man war ja aufeinander angewiesen,
v.a. früher,
als es noch viel Handarbeit
und keine Maschinen gab.
Damals musste man natürlich
noch mehr zusammenarbeiten.
Hallo!
- Hallo!
Ich war mit Niklaus Winter
von Anfang an sehr gut befreundet.
Im Lauf der Jahre wurde
diese Freundschaft immer stärker -
auch privat.
Wenn ich etwas hatte, half er mir.
Er wurde
zu einem meiner besten Kollegen.
Ciao!
- Einen schönen Tag!
* Beschwingte Musik *
Mein Papa ist im Kanton Aargau
aufgewachsen - im Fricktal.
In Kaisten.
Er hat die Rekrutenschule
in Sion absolviert,
in der Hauptstadt
des Kantons Wallis.
Dort lernte er meine Mama kennen.
Meine Mama
arbeitete im Krankenhaus in Sion.
Das war 1978.
Und damals war es noch so,
dass man seine Arbeitsstelle
zusammen mit einer Wohnung bekam.
Darum zogen wir im Bahnhof
in Hohtenn im oberen Stockwerk ein.
Ich habe
als ganz junger Fahrdienstleiter
die Versetzung ins Wallis bekommen.
Ich ging nicht so gerne.
Zuerst war ich in Hohtenn.
Dort wohnte ich zwei Jahre lang
in dem Haus,
in dem Niklaus Winter lebte,
bevor ich nach Goppenstein ging.
Dort war
die ganze Fernsteuerzentrale.
So kam ich ins Lötschental.
Dort lernte ich auch
Otto Henzen kennen,
der damals
noch beim Autoverlad arbeitete.
* Sanfte Musik *
Otto ...
Na ja, als verschlossen
möchte ich ihn nicht beschreiben,
aber er war sehr ruhig.
Er war wirklich sehr ruhig.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern,
dass er je in eine Hektik gekommen
oder nervös gewesen wäre.
Also ich habe ihn
als sehr ruhig in Erinnerung.
Privat unternahmen wir jeweils
etwas zusammen.
Er war sogar an unserer Hochzeit,
die wir im Wallis feierten.
Na ja, ich würde sagen,
mit ihm habe ich noch
andere Worte gesprochen
als nur dienstliche.
* Sanfte Musik *
Otto Henzen
kam aus Blatten im Lötschental.
Sie haben dort
einen anderen Charakter.
Wie er privat war,
weiss ich natürlich weniger.
Aber bei der Arbeit
war er sehr, sehr genau.
Er war fast zu übervorsichtig.
Er war immer
in einer gewissen Spannung.
Das war so mein Eindruck.
Menschlich und so
kam er mit allen zurecht.
Er war
ein angenehmer Arbeitskollege.
(Originalton aus Radio)
ist beim Schweizer Alpen-Club SAC
das Jahr der Hütte.
Jetzt weiter zum Wetter.
Am Abend und in der ersten Nacht-
hälfte sind am Nordrand des Landes
kräftige Gewitter mit Hagel
und Sturmböen wahrscheinlich.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmusik *
Ich habe Betriebsdisponent gelernt.
1974 habe ich begonnen.
Ich habe meine Lehre
bei der SBB gemacht.
Und ich habe dort
30 Jahre lang gearbeitet.
Man war einfach auf diesen kleinen
Bahnhöfen und hat alles gemacht -
also Billette verkauft,
Güterverkehr, Stellwerke bedient.
Ich war für die SBB in Thun
und wechselte dann nach Spiez
zur BLS.
Heute
ist das reine Bildschirmarbeit.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmusik *
Also, das ist bis heute so.
Man hat die Nachtschicht
in der Regel eine ganze Woche lang.
Da arbeitet man von 20 Uhr
bis 4 Uhr.
Um 4 Uhr geht man nach Hause,
um zu schlafen.
Um die Mittagszeit herum,
um 13 Uhr, steht man wieder auf.
An jenem Tag
stand ich auch am Mittag auf
und ging ganz normal zur Arbeit.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Mein Papa sagte mir dann auch noch,
er hätte an jenem Tag
arbeiten sollen.
Er habe aber gesagt,
er wolle den Tag über freimachen
und dann abends und nachts arbeiten,
weil die Nachtschichten
so anstrengend seien.
Und ich sagte noch zu ihm,
es sei richtig,
dass er tagsüber nicht arbeite,
denn ...
Ja, man kann ja nicht
Tag und Nacht arbeiten.
Das fände ich auch gut so.
Das sei die richtige Entscheidung.
Hallo!
- Hallo, Otto! Geht es dir gut?
Ja, und selber?
Mir auch.
Ich war am Arbeitsplatz Thun.
Ich bediente den Bahnhof Thun
plus einen Teil des Aaretals,
also Richtung Bern.
Das war mein Sektor.
Ja, 32-42. Wie?
Willst du meinen Fünfer übernehmen?
- Ja, ich schiebe ihn rüber.
* Telefonklingeln *
Ja, das mache ich gleich.
- Bist du morgen auch hier?
Oder haben wir mal etwas Ruhe?
Achtung, Nummer 3 kommt zu dir.
- Okay.
* Beklemmende Musik *
* Düstere Musik *
Ich war in jener Nacht Dispatcher
in der Betriebszentrale in Spiez.
Mir standen Fahrdienstleiter
zur Seite -
ein jüngerer
und ein älterer Fahrdienstleiter.
Sie haben beide eine
herkömmliche Ausbildung absolviert.
Es war eigentlich
eine ganz normale Situation,
wie sie nachts vorkommt.
Mehr Güterverkehr als Reisezüge.
Aufgrund verschiedener Baustellen,
die wir hatten,
mussten wir diesen Güterverkehr
entsprechend disponieren,
dass man an diesen Baustellen
gut vorbeikam.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Aber heute Morgen
musstest du nicht arbeiten?
Wie?
Heute Morgen
musstest du nicht arbeiten?
Nein.
An jenem Abend
war bereits ein grösseres Ereignis
in Form eines Personenunfalls
im Aaretal,
im Bereich von Münsingen.
Das führte zu erheblichen
Verspätungen im Güterverkehr
und zu einzelnen Zugsausfällen
im Personenverkehr.
Was genau, wissen wir auch nicht.
Einfach die Meldung
eines Lokführers,
dass jemand unter den Zug geriet.
In der Regel dauert es mehrere
Stunden, bis das untersucht ist.
Dadurch hatten wir
einen Totalunterbruch im Aaretal.
Und es gab einen Rückstau.
Ja, es war ziemlich viel los.
Es gab auch sonst viele Bauarbeiten.
Im Mai
ist sowieso immer stark Bausaison.
Ja, es war ziemlich kurzweilig.
Wenn dieses Münsingen nicht wäre!
Ja.
Ja, ich habe dich
in die Zwei gestellt. Das ist neu.
Wir haben ein Chaos, das stimmt.
Es tut mir leid. Was?
Ja, jetzt musst du dort
halt kurz warten.
Oh, Mann! Ehrlich!
Mit den vielen Güterzügen,
die über den Lötschberg fahren ...
Damals waren es rund 100 Güterzüge
in 24 Stunden.
Diese verkehren v.a. nachts.
Da kommt eine Ballung
dieser Güterzüge vor.
Die Strecke war dann unterbrochen,
bis
die kantonale Untersuchungsstelle
die Unfallstelle freigab.
Dadurch haben sich Güterzüge
Richtung Norden und Süden gestaut.
Darum standen so viele
auch im Bahnhof Thun.
In dieser Nacht
wurde beim Bahnhof Blausee-Mitholz
eine Weiche umgebaut.
Winter und Henzen
waren dort als Lokführer eingesetzt
und arbeiteten
in dieser Baugruppe mit.
Lutz, ich habe noch etwas gefunden.
Ich bin sehr müde.
Ich könnte im Stehen einschlafen.
Ja, ich fahre euch jetzt nach Hause.
Dann wird das gut.
Endspurt.
- Ja, komm!
Pardon,
wir müssen hier schnell vorbei!
Legt das Zeug hinein!
Es gibt Weichen, die durch
einen Neubau ersetzt werden müssen.
Da wird meist nicht nur
die Weiche selbst umgebaut,
sondern auch der Unterbau,
das Schotterbett.
Also mit Neuschotter belegt
und eine neue Weiche eingebaut.
Ich kann mich erinnern:
Klaus kam noch kurz bei mir vorbei.
Dann habe ich mit ihm
noch ein Spässchen gemacht.
Wir haben einander
ja schon seit Jahrzehnten gekannt.
Man sah bei Winter
eigentlich keine Anspannung.
* Maschinengeräusch *
(TV-Stimme)
Eine eigene Schule, italienische
Läden und Restaurants ...
Wir sahen fern.
Da hatten wir es noch davon,
warum Papa sich wohl
solche Sorgen gemacht hatte.
Wir sprachen auch noch darüber.
Ja, und er rief Mama nochmals an,
bevor wir schlafen gingen.
Das war gegen 22 Uhr.
Ja, hallo!
Wie?
Bist du eingeschlafen?
Ja, ich auch fast.
Er sagte, alles sei in Ordnung,
alles laufe bestens.
Da war sie auch froh.
Dann legten wir uns schlafen.
So, wie ich mich heute erinnere,
gab es in Blausee eine Baustelle.
Diese wurde dann
von Kandersteg aus bedient.
Wir bekamen
gar nicht viel davon mit.
Was sie genau machen,
wissen wir in der Regel nicht.
Ich bin bei Weiche 54
und fahre bereits.
Dann Rangierfahrt Kandergrund.
Und nachher Dienst extra, Gleis 5.
Also: Winter Klaus, 89-9-61-R bei
Blausee aufs gesicherte Gleis 220
Richtung Kandergrund abfahren.
Und Henzen als 89-9-60-R
ist nach wie vor auf 200 unterwegs.
Verstanden. 89-9-61-R kann abfahren.
Auf Weiche 54 Richtung Kandergrund.
Ist Henzen schon in Kandergrund?
Äh ... Er fährt gerade
auf dem Einfahrtssignal.
Er meldet sich demnächst zurück.
Ihre Aufgabe war es,
verschiedene Baumaschinen und Wagen
von der Arbeitsstelle Blausee
runter nach Frutigen zu bringen.
Schliesslich sollten sie noch den
Altschotter bei der Kiestag kippen,
wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
89-9-60-R Henzen von Kandersteg,
antworten.
89-9-60-R verstanden, antworten.
So, wie ich es sehe, bist du bereits
innerhalb des Signals.
Ja.
Ich bin jetzt innerhalb des Signals
in Kandergrund.
Gut, dann mache ich dir auf.
Weiterfahrt wäre nachher 36-2-40.
Nach Beenden seiner Arbeit
fuhr Lokführer Henzen
mit den sieben Wagen nach Frutigen.
Winter fuhr anschliessend
eine Baumaschine nach Frutigen.
Was nimmst du?
- Ohne.
Ohne. Ist gut.
- Also ohne Zucker.
Ja, ja.
Aber von deinem gibt es keine mehr.
Du musst wieder welche bringen.
Du hast meine aufgebraucht.
Ja, ist gut.
- Ich gebe dir einen von Vreni.
Die Lage
hat sich eigentlich entspannt -
auch mit dem Güterverkehr.
So gegen 2.30 Uhr morgens
hatten wir das Gefühl,
jetzt hätten wir es überstanden
und hätten es ruhig -
bis zum Feierabend,
der um 4 Uhr geplant war.
Ich mag mich noch erinnern.
Das war ein Gesprächsfetzen,
den ich noch weiss.
Wir hatten
zwischen 2 Uhr und 3 Uhr gesagt:
"So, jetzt haben wir aufgeräumt."
"Bis zum Feierabend
nehmen wir es noch gemütlich."
Also!
- Schau da!
Danke!
- Bitte!
So!
In Frutigen fuhr diese Komposition
mit sieben Wagen ein.
Dann stellte man eine Bremsstörung
an einem Wagen fest.
Man konnte
diese blockierte Bremse lösen,
aber es gab beim Radsatz
eine Schleifstelle.
So konnte der Wagen
nicht mehr auf die Strecke fahren.
Er wurde mit dem
zugehörigen Schutzwagen ausrangiert.
Das war eigentlich
ein routinemässiges,
aber damals in Frutigen
ein sehr zeitaufwendiges Rangieren.
* Er pfeift. *
Anschliessend
bestand die Komposition
mit dem Schienentraktor
aus fünf Wagen.
Die Anhängelast betrug 300 t.
Hallo?
Ja, Klaus. Äh ... Hast du die
Handbremse angezogen oder so was?
Da löst sich etwas nicht.
Ich sehe gleich nach.
Ich muss schnell runter,
die Maschinen ausladen.
Es kommt nur einer mit uns mit.
Aha! Ja ...
Ich überprüfe das inzwischen mal.
Gut.
Das waren
keine vollausgebildeten Lokführer,
die Schnellzüge zwischen Zürich
und Genf betreuen würden.
Sondern das waren Lokführer,
die für beschränkte Aufgaben
ausgebildet waren.
Der eine
durfte mit maximal 100 km/h fahren,
aber nur sehr beschränkt
mit Reisezügen.
Und der andere durfte überhaupt nur
mit kleinen Traktoren fahren.
Also sie kannten
die Fahrdienstvorschriften bestimmt,
aber wie weit ihre Ausbildung
und Erfahrung reichte ...
Der eine hatte seine Prüfung
erst kurz zuvor abgelegt.
Inwieweit ihre Erfahrung
und ihr Fachwissen reichte,
um eine Störung richtig
zu diagnostizieren und zu beheben,
kann ich im Nachhinein
nicht beurteilen.
* Düstere Musik *
* Zischen *
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ja, wenn die Bremse eines Wagens
blockiert ist,
kann man an einem Auslöseventil
beim Wagen
die Luft
aus dem Bremsbehälter rauslassen.
Und wenn sämtliche Luft
entwichen ist,
kann man die Bremse lösen.
Heute in Neudeutsch
würde man wohl "resetten" sagen.
Bahntechnisch
nennt man das "melken".
Dieser Vorgang heisst "melken",
weil es auf der Seite des Wagens
eine Stange gibt,
an der man ziehen kann.
Sie löst beim Bremszylinder,
wenn ich mich nicht irre,
das Ablassventil.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Gut.
Wenn man nach dem Melken
keine Ursache findet
für die Störung an dem Wagen -
es könnte z.B. noch
die Handbremse angezogen sein -,
ist der Bremsvorgang zu wiederholen.
Man lässt also wieder Luft
in den Bremsbehälter,
lässt Luft ab und bremst
und löst dann wieder.
Hast du die Bremsprobe gemacht
oder muss ich sie machen?
Ich habe die Bremsprobe gemacht, ja.
Ich musste zuerst alle melken.
Alle waren angezogen.
Schon wieder?
Ja, ja.
Korrekt wäre, dass man bremst
und die Bremse wieder löst -
durch den Lokführer
auf der Lokomotive.
Ein weiterer Mitarbeiter
muss am Zug entlanggehen
und bei jedem Radsatz kontrollieren,
ob die Bremse gelöst ist
oder eben anliegt.
Und dann weiss man:
Wenn beide Zustände überall
erreicht sind, ist die Bremse gut.
Diese Lokführer waren sehr erfahren
und ... äh ...
Sie haben eigentlich das gemacht,
was jeder Lokführer macht:
Ohne Bremsprobe
fährt man nicht auf die Strecke.
Wie sie diese gemacht haben, ist im
Nachhinein nicht mehr zu erklären.
Ist die Bremse gut?
Die Bremse war nachher gut, ja.
Ich weiss, Klaus mit den
Bremsproben - das vergesse ich nie:
Er hat immer gesagt ...
Eine machte man ja normal.
Dann machte er noch eine zweite.
Er sagte: "Otto,
mach noch eine zweite Bremsprobe!"
Es kam vor, dass ich auch noch
eine dritte machen musste.
Ich sagte mir danach immer:
"Das kann es nicht geben!"
"Ausgerechnet er, der so
auf diese Bremsproben fixiert war -
das weiss ich
aus eigener Erfahrung -,
und dann passiert so etwas!"
Es ist einfach schwer,
das zu verstehen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Im Zug reisten auch drei Mitarbeiter
einer privaten Gleisbaufirma mit.
Jungs, ihr könnt nach Hause gehen.
Ich schaffe das alleine.
Wiedersehen!
- Gute Nacht!
Nach Ankunft in Frutigen sagte
Lutz Hanath seinen beiden Kollegen,
sie könnten nach Hause gehen.
Er könne die Abladearbeiten
im Kieswerk alleine bewältigen.
Lutz Hanaths Entscheid
rettete diesen beiden das Leben.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Ah!
So!
So, ja. Henzen, Frutigen im Drei.
Jetzt hätte ich gerne ...
... einen Dienstextrazug,
einen TM, und fünf Wagen.
Jetzt habe ich eine Frage:
Ist es möglich,
direkt in die Kiestag zu fahren
oder muss ich erst
nach Spiez kommen?
Nein, du kannst direkt fahren.
Das geht schon.
Einen TM und fünf Wagen ...
Frutigen - Hondrich-Süd.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Irgendwann waren sie
mit ihren Manövern fertig.
Sie wollten Richtung Hondrich-Süd
in das Anschlussgleis fahren.
Das gibt es heute noch.
Sie wollten Altschotter abladen.
Wie sieht es denn
mit der Rückfahrt aus?
Ja ...
Wir brauchen etwa ...
... 20 Minuten, um abzuladen,
und müssten danach
natürlich wieder rauf nach Frutigen.
Das ist gut.
Und dann zeige ich dir etwas an
für in den Hondrich.
Jawohl,
du kannst mir etwas anzeigen.
Und ich bin ...
Ich bin eigentlich fahrbereit.
Wenn du etwas hast,
kannst du es mir melden.
Er meldete den Zug an
und bekam eine Zugnummer.
Jeder Zug muss ja eine Nummer haben.
Henzen, ich öffne dir in Frutigen.
Du heisst 36-2-63.
Retour 36-2-64.
Henzen in Frutigen, verstanden.
Ich heisse 36-2-63
und nachher 36-2-64.
Richtig!
Und im Hondrich
lasse ich dich ins 1K.
Gut!
Das war Henzen aus dem Wallis, oder?
- Henzen kommt aus dem Wallis, ja.
Ein netter Kerl.
- Ja.
Dann gehen wir.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Mein Vater hatte mir vieles
von der Arbeit erzählt.
Er müsse halt
sehr viele Tonnen transportieren.
Und er hatte mir auch gesagt,
wenn die Bremsen
nicht funktionierten,
habe man keine Chance.
Da müsse man den Kopf
schon bei der Sache haben
und exakt arbeiten.
* Beklemmende Musik *
Ah!
Mist, da passiert gar nichts!
Das gibt es ja nicht!
Komm! Bremse!
Schublade 2.
Kannst du sie mir rübergeben?
Ja, ich habe sie dir rübergeschoben.
Hast du
all meine Protokolle rausgenommen?
Nein.
- Lege dir doch selber Kopien an!
* Telefonklingeln *
Fahrdienst Spiez.
* Rauschen *
Henzen.
Fahrdienst Spiez, antworten!
* Rauschen *
Hey, hey!
Fahrdienst Spiez ist da. Antworten!
* Rauschen *
Bremse!
Spiez. Ich verstehe kein Wort.
* Rauschen, undeutliche Stimme *
Die Verständigung
war ziemlich schlecht.
Das ist im Nachhinein
auch verständlich.
Sie waren vermutlich sehr aufgeregt,
als sie merkten,
dass der Zug nicht bremste.
Ja, es waren bewegende Funksprüche,
die bei mir beim Hören
auch Emotionen auslösten.
Also an den Funkspruch
erinnere ich mich nicht.
Ich habe ihn nicht entgegengenommen.
Der jüngere Fahrdienstleiter
kam mit der Meldung zu mir,
dass dieser Zug unterwegs sei
und nicht mehr bremsen könne.
Für mich
ist das absolut unvorstellbar,
dass ein Zug nicht bremsen kann.
Das gibt es eigentlich gar nicht.
Spiez, antworten!
Hörst du? Wir bremsen nicht!
Fahrdienst Spiez ist da. Antworten!
- Wir bremsen nicht!
Spiez. Ich verstehe kein Wort.
- So eine Scheisse!
Auf der Höhe von Reichenbach,
also etwa vier Minuten nach
dem Start, funkte er ein erstes Mal.
Spiez. Ich verstehe gar nichts.
Ruf mich unter 3443 an!
* Rauschen, undeutliche Stimme *
Man kann es sich fast nicht anhören.
Es tut weh -
v.a. wenn man diese Leute kannte -,
in welche Situation sie gerieten.
Und sie haben ... Sie merkten auch:
Jetzt ist es gar nicht gut.
Scheisse! Bremse!
Bremse, du Scheissmaschine!
Was ist denn los?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Das gibt es ja nicht!
Spiez ist da.
- Wir fahren aus dem Berg!
Wir fahren überall flüssig durch!
Was sagst du?
Du kannst gar nicht bremsen?
Verdammter Scheissdreck!
Die Bremse ...
* Rauschen *
36-2-63, antworten!
Ich weiss nicht mehr genau,
wie er es sagte.
Einfach, dass er
keine Bremsleistung mehr hat.
Wir sollen ihn nicht in den Hondrich
ins Anschlussgleis des Kieswerks
stellen.
36-2-63, antworten!
Ja, Henzen.
Stelle uns gerade durch!
Darunter verstehen wir,
dass man den Zug
nicht noch auf eine Ablenkung lenkt,
z.B. auf eine Weiche,
die man nur
mit 40 km/h befahren darf,
wenn diese
in ablenkender Stellung ist.
Er wollte natürlich,
dass er in der geraden Stellung
weiterfahren kann.
* Dramatische Musik *
36-2-64.
Wir haben keine Bremswirkung.
Ich habe schon 60 km/h.
Wir sind ... äh ... bei Heustrich.
Er wollte nicht über die Kiestag,
weil dort eine Weiche gewesen wäre,
die eine
geringere Geschwindigkeit zulässt.
Er bekam sicher ...
Oder beide bekamen sicher Angst,
dass sie dort entgleisen würden.
Sicher bestand irgendwo
noch die Hoffnung,
dass sich dieses Problem
lösen würde.
Ich nehme an, dass sie sich
nicht ganz bewusst waren,
warum sie keine Bremswirkung hatten
oder dass es irgendwo
eine Möglichkeit gab, sie zu retten.
Deshalb verlangte er auch "gerade",
damit er nirgendwo
auf eine Ablenkung stösst,
sondern möglichst gerade fahren
und vielleicht irgendwo gegen ein
Gefälle nach oben auslaufen kann.
Es ist natürlich klar:
Wenn man den Zug in die Ebene
hätte auslaufen lassen können
und die Lokbremse
ein bisschen gewirkt hätte,
wäre der Zug irgendwann
unter dem Fahrwiderstand
und dieser schwachen Wirkung der
Lokbremse zum Stillstand gekommen.
Aber das hätte unter Umständen
Dutzende von Kilometern beansprucht.
D.h., er hätte auf dem geraden Weg
durch alle Bahnhöfe
und durch Thun hindurch
fahren müssen.
Das Beste wäre gewesen, wenn er
durch Thun hätte fahren können -
Richtung Aaretal.
Er wäre zwar mit 70 km/h
durch den Bahnhof Thun -
in der Hoffnung,
sie könnten vielleicht
irgendwann abspringen.
Vor Thun
hatte er 90 km/h oder 100 km/h,
aber er wäre ins Flache gekommen.
Er hätte sich verlangsamt.
Wegen des Personenunfalls
in Münsingen
war der Bahnhof Thun
mit Zügen versperrt.
Dort auf einen Zug auffahren
konnten wir nicht.
Auf dem einen Gleis
stand eine Rollende Landstrasse -
mit Chauffeuren, die schliefen.
* Beklemmende Musik *
Wäre er dort hineingefahren ...
Stellen Sie sich das vor!
* Undeutliche Stimme über Funk *
Was? Kannst du das wiederholen?
... unbedingt ... drei ... vier ...
Der Funkkontakt brach ab,
als er beim Tunnel war.
Bei Spiez gibt es einen Tunnel.
Dort brach der Kontakt ab.
Wir konnten
keinen Kontakt mehr aufnehmen.
Otto, was ist los?
Scheisse!
Auch über den anderen Funkkanal
kam keine Kommunikation mehr
zustande.
Und sie verstanden mich
wahrscheinlich nicht, weil ...
Ja, ich versuchte, ihnen
noch zu sagen, dass sie mich ...
Ich weiss nicht,
ob sie kein Handy bei sich hatten.
Ich sagte ihnen,
sie sollen mich anrufen.
Ich wusste auch nicht,
was mit ihnen geschah.
Verdammter Scheissdreck!
Ich weiss nicht, was ich tun soll.
Es war ... äh ...
Die Atmosphäre
war sicherlich angespannt,
denn wir drei,
die wir im Büro sassen,
wurden alle zum ersten Mal mit einer
solchen Situation konfrontiert.
Es ist eigentlich eine Situation,
von der man sich nicht
vorstellen kann, dass sie eintrifft.
Und ...
Man muss nachher einfach ...
... schauen, was es gibt,
welche Möglichkeiten wir haben,
um diesen Zug
eventuell zum Bremsen zu bringen.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Nach Thun
können wir ihn nicht lassen.
Dort haben wir
eine Rollende Landstrasse.
Ja, ich kannte
die drei Mitarbeitenden gut.
Es waren sehr erfahrene
und kompetente Fahrdienstleiter.
Sie mussten ...
... eine Entscheidung fällen,
die unter Zeitdruck,
in wenigen Minuten,
gefällt werden musste.
15 Minuten insgesamt.
In diesen 15 Minuten
mussten sie in Spiez begreifen:
Was passiert überhaupt?
Was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Prüfen, wo wir den Zug
passieren lassen können.
In welchen Bahnhöfen
waren welche Gleise besetzt,
unter Umständen durch Reisezüge?
15 Minuten -
das ist wahnsinnig wenig.
Wir haben uns überlegt,
wie wir den Zug stoppen könnten,
ohne irgendjemand anderen
zu gefährden.
Da vergehen zehn Minuten wie nichts.
Da haben wir gesagt: "Gut,
lassen wir ihn mal nach Spiez!"
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Dann hatte ich das Gefühl,
ich hätte einen Geistesblitz:
"Stelle ihm
doch keine Hauptsignale!"
"Lasse ihn doch über
die geschlossenen Signale fahren!"
"Wenn er über
die geschlossenen Signale fährt,
stoppt der Zug jederzeit."
So hat man es gelernt.
Ein automatisches Bremssystem
stoppt den Zug dann.
Das funktionierte
bei diesem Bauzug leider nicht,
denn die schwere Anhängerlast
schob den Zug vor sich her -
ungeachtet jeder Signalstellung.
Hörst du mich?
* Düstere Musik *
Natürlich wäre das Schönste gewesen,
hätte man den Zug
durch das Simmental leiten können,
aber da gab es in Spiez
eine Baustelle.
Und nach Spiez,
Richtung Simmental, war auch eine.
Es hätte nicht gereicht, die Leute
von der Baustelle zu warnen.
Der Fahrweg von Frutigen über
den Bahnhof Spiez Richtung Simmental
führte über eine Weiche mit einer
Geschwindigkeit von maximal 40 km/h.
Sie mussten annehmen, dass
bei der Geschwindigkeit des Bauzuges
dieser
im Bahnhof Spiez entgleist wäre.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Scheisse!
Bremse! Bremse!
Die Achsen des Schienentraktors
glühten und sprühten Funken.
Und das ist
das offensichtliche Zeichen dafür,
dass es beim Schienentraktor
eine hohe Bremswirkung gab.
Die schwere Anhängerlast
schob den Zug vor sich her.
Und die Bremskraft
des Schienentraktors
genügte
bei dieser Geschwindigkeit nicht,
um den Zug zu stoppen.
Wir achteten darauf,
dass von Thun keine weiteren Züge
in Richtung Spiez fuhren,
sodass wir sicher keinen Zug in der
Gegenrichtung des Bauzuges hatten,
weil er sich auch im Bahnhof Spiez
nirgends bremsen liess.
In Gwatt, 41 -
das kannst du vergessen.
Das Gleis führt in den Bahnhof.
* Rauschen *
* Düstere Musik *
Ich sah nur noch
das Dach der Lokomotive,
als der Zug auf Gleis 3 durchfuhr.
Es sind ja 60 km/h durch den
Bahnhof Spiez, aber er hatte mehr.
Ich habe gar nicht
aus dem Fenster gesehen.
Ich habe - und das ist etwas,
das sich wirklich eingebrannt hat -
den roten Strich
auf dem Bildschirm ...
Im Prinzip einfach dieser Zug,
der immer weiterfuhr.
Das ist ein Bild,
das sich eingebrannt hat.
* Gleichmässiges Piepsen *
* Beklemmende Musik *
Aber das Perfide war,
dass ich keine Ahnung hatte, wie
viele Leute auf diesem Zug waren.
Ich wusste: Zwei Personen
müssen mindestens mitfahren,
aber ich wusste nicht,
ob noch mehr mitfuhren.
Ob es um Leben und Tod ging ...
Damit setzten wir uns
eigentlich nicht auseinander,
denn wir brauchten einfach ...
... Zeit, um zu kämpfen
und Ideen zu haben,
wie wir diesen Leuten
helfen könnten.
Also für uns gab es eigentlich
nur die Möglichkeit Leben.
Und ich glaube,
von uns dreien dachte niemand daran,
dass es Opfer geben könnte.
Wir hofften,
dass er nach dem Bahnhof Spiez,
wo es flacher wird, anhalten kann
oder stark verlangsamt.
Das war aber nicht der Fall,
im Gegenteil. Es bleibt ein Gefälle.
Nach dem Bahnhof Spiez geht es
wieder runter bis kurz vor Thun.
* Düstere Musik *
Ich machte mir Gedanken,
was in ihnen vorging.
Das muss enorm brutal gewesen sein.
Sie hatten sicher ...
... die Hoffnung,
dass es eine Lösung gibt.
Sie haben ja die betriebliche
Situation nicht gekannt.
Was sie sich ganz sicher
nicht vorstellen konnten, war,
dass der Bahnhof Thun
mit Zügen belegt ist.
Dessen
waren sie sich sicher nicht bewusst.
Wenn man in der Nacht in diesem
Höllentempo da runterfährt ...
Es gab Funken und war doch heiss
in der Rangierlokomotive,
könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Sie waren bestimmt verzweifelt.
Das muss also
sehr, sehr schlimm gewesen sein,
was sie erlebten.
Ja,
das ist praktisch unbeschreiblich.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ja, das war nachher
so eine rollende Planung.
Wir hatten ja
unglaublichen Zeitdruck.
Es dauerte ja nur einige Minuten -
und ging immer weiter.
Nachher dachten wir daran,
in Gwatt in dieses Gleis 1 zu fahren
und den Zug
dort auslaufen zu lassen,
in dieses Stumpengleis.
Die Weiche dort war früher
noch nicht fernsteuerbar.
Ich kannte den ehemaligen Vorsteher
damals persönlich.
Ich wusste einfach,
wie es dort aussieht,
weil ich ja in der Region wohne.
* Düstere Musik *
Der ehemalige Bahnhofvorsteher
wohnte oben in der Wohnung,
aber er bekam davon
natürlich nichts mit.
Dass wir den Gedanken hatten,
den Zug in das Haus zu lenken,
wusste er natürlich nicht.
Und die nächste Variante wäre
wieder ein Anschlussgleis gewesen -
bei der Ausfahrt aus dem Bahnhof
Gwatt. Das war ein Firmengebäude.
Dort wussten wir nicht,
ob Personen bei der Arbeit waren.
Es führte über einen Privatübergang.
Es gab zusätzlich
eine ungesicherte Strasse.
Und wir wussten auch nicht,
ob in dieser Fabrik
Chemikalien gelagert waren.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Jetzt bremse mal, verdammt nochmals!
Scheisse!
Ja, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass sie daran dachten,
vom Zug abzuspringen.
Bei dieser Geschwindigkeit
abzuspringen auf offener Strecke,
auf Schienen, auf Schotter ...
Ich glaube, das ist nicht möglich.
Auf der Seite der Gleise
sind Fahrleitungsmasten.
An ihnen
sind die Fahrleitungen befestigt.
Und diese
stehen in solch kurzen Abständen,
dass man bei dieser Geschwindigkeit
von über 80 km/h
eigentlich gar nicht aus
diesen Fahrzeugen abspringen kann,
ohne einen Fahrleitungsmast
zu treffen.
Otto!
Ich habe schon mal davon gelesen,
dass es Fälle gab,
bei denen man mit einer Lokomotive
einen "entlaufenen" Zug auffing.
Theoretisch, also physikalisch,
wenn man so sagen will,
ist das machbar.
Aber das würde voraussetzen,
dass man um 3.15 Uhr im Bahnhof
Spiez auf dem durchgehenden Gleis
eine Lokomotive mit einem Lokführer
stehen hat,
der bereit ist, das zu machen.
Den kann man
nicht irgendwo aufbieten
oder die Lokomotive
aus dem Depot holen.
Das reicht zeitlich nicht.
Er hätte mit einem gewissen
zeitlichen Abstand vorausfahren
und versuchen müssen, sich der
Geschwindigkeit des Zuges anzupassen
und ihn dann auffangen
und abbremsen müssen.
Solch abenteuerliche Geschichten
gab es wirklich schon,
aber das gelingt nicht mal
in einem Prozent der Fälle.
Das sind absolute Ausnahmefälle
und wäre in diesem Moment
wahrscheinlich
absolut unrealistisch gewesen.
* Düstere Musik *
Ich war bei vielen
Eisenbahnbaustellen dabei.
In Bezug auf die Sicherheit
schien mir das nicht immer gut.
Ein Teil der Leute nahm die
Sicherheit nicht so ernst wie ich.
Das war etwas schwierig.
Zudem war ich der Älteste
der Abteilung.
Ausserdem
schien es mir nicht so gut,
dass der Älteste der Abteilung
noch Nachtschichten machen sollte -
kurz vor der Pensionierung.
Wir waren neun Leute.
Ein Bauzug von 350 t.
Zwei Bohrmänner
und einfach Beihilfen -
Maschinisten von uns, Kranführer.
In Dürrenast-Station
brach man ein Perron ab.
Dort war eine Equipe
mit einem Sicherheitswärter.
Und hier bei der Einheit
der Lärmschutzwände
war auch ein Sicherheitswärter.
Wenn
auf einer doppelgleisigen Strecke
auf dem einen Gleis gearbeitet wird
und auf dem anderen Gleis
der Zugbetrieb abgewickelt wird,
ist das schon
eine sehr gefährliche Situation.
Darum hat man auch Sicherheitswärter
im Einsatz,
die informiert werden,
wann der nächste Zug kommt.
Aber man muss klar sehen:
Sie bewegen sich
auf einem schmalen Areal,
nämlich auf dem Gleis,
an dem sie arbeiten.
Das ist ein Raum von vielleicht
drei bis vier Metern,
wo sie sich bewegen können.
Also das ist
keine ungefährliche Situation.
* Düstere Musik *
Auf 41 können wir ihn nicht leiten.
Dort entgleist er uns
und fährt ins Bahnhofshaus.
21 geht auch nicht.
Dort entgleist er uns
und fährt zur Strasse.
Also lenken wir ihn
auf das gesperrte Streckengleis,
auf dem der Bauzug steht.
Das machte einem schon Angst.
Wir wussten ja:
Der Zug ist ausser Kontrolle.
Dann blieb nur
diese Baustelle übrig.
Ja, diese Ausweglosigkeit,
die insgesamt bestand ...
Diese Verzweiflung auf dem Zug
und unter den Fahrdienstleitern
in der Betriebszentrale ...
... muss für sie
furchtbar gewesen sein.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Man musste diesen Zug bremsen.
Und das heisst ganz klar:
Man musste ihn
zum Entgleisen bringen.
Das ist ganz klar:
Wenn durch die weitere Fahrt
Menschen gefährdet werden,
dann muss man ihn
zum Entgleisen bringen,
sonst wird die Katastrophe
noch grösser.
Und jetzt musst du anrufen.
Sie haben schliesslich
nach den in der Schweiz
geltenden Fahrdienstvorschriften
gehandelt.
Darin heisst es:
"Die entlaufenen Fahrzeuge
sind mit allen zur Verfügung
stehenden Mitteln aufzuhalten."
"Gelingt dies nicht,
sind sie zum Entgleisen zu bringen."
* Düstere Musik *
Ja, ich habe mich dort in den
Bereich meines Kollegen eingemischt.
Denn für mich war klar,
dass ich ihm nicht sagen konnte:
"Stell ihn weiter!"
Die letzte Weiche bei dieser
Komposition habe ich gestellt -
also in vollem Bewusstsein.
Bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt
hatte ich funktioniert und dann ...
Also wir hofften natürlich,
sie könnten runterspringen.
Aber dass es so schlimm endet,
fand man erst im Nachhinein hinaus.
In der Nacht zuvor hatten wir
mit dem grossen Bagger eine Panne.
Auf beiden Seiten
war er eingedrückt.
Die Deichsel war noch etwa so lange.
Normalerweise sind sie 1,5 m lang.
Ja, dann nahm man den kleinen Bagger
für die Nacht,
damit man trotzdem etwas tun konnte.
Auf dieser Baustelle sind Arbeiter,
die auch beschäftigt sein wollen.
Man hatte ein Notprogramm mit
dem Abbruch des Dürrenast-Bahnhofs.
Die Portugiesen
trennten mit dem Schneidbrenner
die Eisenträger des Bahnhofs ab.
Ich hob das Zeug dann mit dem Bagger
rüber in den Bahnwagen.
Sonst wäre man nicht hingekommen,
ausser vom Gleis her.
Man machte den Rückbau mit der Bahn.
Nach Mitternacht waren wir fertig.
Dann ging ich die Gleise entlang
und fragte den Polier, Michael,
ob es in Ordnung wäre,
wenn ich gehe.
Die Abmachung mit dem Polier war,
dass ich eher heimgehen könne,
um zu schlafen.
So könnte ich tagsüber
den grossen Bagger reparieren.
Es war so: Der Gleisbagger
in Dürrenast war fertig.
Nachher
fuhr unser Sicherheitswärter ...
... mit diesem Gleisbagger
und dem Maschinisten nach Gwatt,
weil man dort Weichen stellen
und Gleise sperren musste,
damit dieser
aufs Abstellgleis fahren konnte.
Dieser Sicherheitswärter kam zurück
und sagte,
er habe von Spiez
eben einen Funkspruch erhalten,
es seien Wagen zu uns unterwegs,
die man nicht bremsen könne.
Wenn wir dort
keinen Kontakt gehabt hätten ...
... weiss ich auch nicht.
Sollen wir einen Hemmschuh legen?
Hör zu! Wo bist du jetzt?
Auf der Höhe
der ehemaligen Station Dürrenast.
Du müsstest unbedingt
in Richtung Gwatt gehen.
Ja ...
Und bleib unbedingt am Telefon!
Der Zug fährt mit etwa 60 km/h.
Und ihr müsst sofort
diese Baustelle räumen!
Na ja, also ...
- Der Zug kann nicht mehr bremsen.
Er fährt mit etwa 80 km/h
auf euch zu!
Nein, also wir bohren hier gerade.
Ja, das stimmt, aber wir
können den Zug nicht stoppen.
Er hat keine Bremsen.
Wir hatten
rund sechs, sieben Minuten Zeit.
Wir mussten ihnen
ja auch noch Fluchtzeit bieten.
Und ... äh ...
das war nicht mal so einfach.
Im ersten Moment
wollten sie uns die Nachricht,
die wir ihnen über Funk
übermitteln wollten, nicht glauben.
Ich bin am Telefon.
Eben, ich sage es ihnen ja.
Ja, ist gut!
Nein.
Aber es dauert
noch ein paar Sekunden,
dann müssen wir entscheiden.
- Und dann?
Es reicht noch.
- Was?
- Ja, also ...
Es dauert,
bis wir hier geräumt haben.
Das war
eine extrem schwierige Situation.
Er hat ein gesperrtes Gleis
und muss nie einen Zug erwarten.
Wenn es Rangierbewegungen gibt,
die zur Baustelle führen würden,
um Materialtransporte zu machen,
sind diese angekündigt.
Das weiss man.
Und ich kann mir schon vorstellen:
Die Situation,
die sie ihm schildern ...
Was heisst es, das umzusetzen?
Man muss auch sehen: Er konnte
nicht einfach alles räumen lassen.
Also er hatte
eine sehr schwierige Situation.
Nein, wir sind ja
komplett auseinandergerissen.
Hör zu: Ihr müsst unbedingt weg!
Die Personen sind das Wichtigste!
Wie reagiert man auf etwas,
das man nicht kennt?
Das ist etwas so Schwieriges,
dass ...
... dass ich auch solche Reaktionen,
eben dass man nicht begreifen will,
dass man zur Seite gehen muss ...
... dass solche Reaktionen
auch Platz haben.
Es ist schwierig, nachzuvollziehen,
dass der Zug ungebremst einfährt.
Wie?
- Dass du den Hemmschuh legst.
Hemmschuh?
- Möglichst weit Richtung Gwatt.
Ja, ja, ja, ja!
- Geht von den Gleisen weg!
Die Personen
sind jetzt das Wichtigste!
Hemmschuh?
- Einen Hemmschuh legen!
Man legt Hemmschuhe aufs Gleis.
Sie sind etwa so lang
und vielleicht 10 kg schwer.
Der Wagen fährt mit dem Rad
sozusagen auf eine Zunge.
Hier ist der Keil.
Dann blockiert es das Rad.
Der Keil wird auf der Schiene
geschoben, bis der Zug hält.
Ich fragte ihn, auf welchem Gleis
wir sie legen sollen.
Wir fragten nach,
wo wir die Hemmschuhe legen sollten.
Sie wussten aber nicht,
auf welchem Gleis der Zug kam.
Kommt er denn ...
- Er kommt jetzt!
Er ist gleich in Gwatt!
Er fährt mit 80 km/h!
Den musste man
richtig in den Hintern treten.
Darum glaubten sie gar nicht,
dass sie sich
in Sicherheit bringen mussten.
Er wäre
wie ein normaler Zug durchgefahren.
Nachher diskutierten wir zusammen,
wobei das schnell ging.
Ich sagte,
dass wir besser wegrennen.
Alle Leute vom Bauzug runter.
Und in Deckung. Wir wussten
ja nicht, was passieren würde.
Kaum hatte man das gesagt ...
... sagte unser Lokführer,
der zuhinterst im Bauzug war,
er steige nicht aus.
Es kämen ein paar Wagen
und gebe nur einen Rums.
So, wie ich mich kenne,
wäre ich wohl nicht sofort
aus dem Bagger gesprungen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, das wäre
ein bisschen bachab gegangen.
Ich hatte auch kein Funkgerät
im Bagger.
Darum hätte ich es nie vernommen.
In Richtung Gwatt!
Man wusste nicht,
ob der Zug auf dem Betriebs-
oder dem Baustellengleis
einfahren würde.
Also eine aussichtslose Situation.
Jetzt raus!
- Was?
Sag es Greub!
- Greub, komm!
Nachher müssen wir rennen!
- Geh jetzt raus!
Jetzt raus!
Hey! Hey! Ihr müsst zur Seite!
Geh jetzt raus!
Hey! Geht rüber!
Geht zur Seite!
Ich sagte, es wäre gut,
wenn er absteigen würde.
Ich würde nicht warten,
wir müssten weg.
* Alarmsignal *
Alarm! Zur Seite! Geht runter!
Dort runter!
* Pfeifton *
* Dramatische Musik *
Nachher rumpelte es in Dürrenast.
Dann stieg er doch endlich aus.
Wir rannten etwa 30 m
ins Blumenfeld,
bis der Zug um die Kurve kam.
Er funkte und rumpelte.
Man wusste nicht,
was es eigentlich war.
Es dauerte etwa 30 Sekunden,
bis es bei uns auch knallte.
Polizeinotruf.
Hier ist
die Betriebsleitzentrale BLS Spiez.
Wir haben ein grösseres Ereignis
in Dürrenast.
Und zwar ist uns
ein Dienstextrazug entlaufen,
der nicht mehr bremsen konnte.
Er fuhr in eine Baustelle.
Wir haben Verletzte und brauchen
die Sanität plus die Feuerwehr,
denn es besteht die Gefahr,
dass das Ganze zu brennen beginnt.
Ja. Und wo ist das?
Das wäre auf der Höhe der alten,
ehemaligen Haltestelle Dürrenast.
Verstanden.
Höhe Dürrenast, Extrazug entgleist.
Genau.
- Danke! Ist gut!
Ich leite das so weiter.
- Danke vielmals! Wiederhören!
Äh ... Die Strassenrettung
brauchen Sie nicht?
Um jemanden herauszuholen,
der eingeklemmt ist?
Ich weiss nicht, ob die Personen
eingeklemmt sind oder nicht.
Wissen Sie,
wie viele Verletzte es sind?
Einen kleinen Moment!
Du weisst nicht,
wie viele Verletzte es sind, oder?
Nein, es ist nicht bekannt. Danke!
Mein Schlafzimmer
liegt in Richtung Bahngleise.
Die Distanz beträgt etwa 60 m.
Und am Morgen um ca. 3.25 Uhr
gab es einen Riesenknall.
Ich wusste nicht, was passiert war,
und ich erschrak mich sehr.
Mein Junior, der damals 16 war,
und ich
trafen uns in der Mitte der Wohnung.
Wir sahen einander an
und wussten nicht, was los war.
Die Alarmanlage der Baustelle
ertönte immer noch.
Etwas leiser
hörte man plötzlich Leute weinen,
die vom Unfallplatz
zur Strasse gegangen waren,
die hinter dem Haus durchführte.
Wir sahen aus dem Fenster und
sahen orange gekleidete Bauarbeiter.
Sie waren vorher
auf dem Gleis oben gewesen.
Wir verstanden nicht,
was geschehen war.
* Alarmsignal *
Was ich sehr selten mache:
Ich hatte mein Handy
in dieser Nacht eingeschaltet
und es an einem Küchentuchhaken
aufgehängt.
Ich konnte es gleich nehmen
und nach Spiez anrufen.
Du, hier auf der Baustelle ...
Es gab vorher einen lauten Knall
und jetzt tönt der Sicherheitsalarm.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob noch jemand da ist.
Doch. Hör zu:
Wir haben eine schreckliche Sache.
Ein Bauzug rollte in Frutigen davon.
Wir mussten ihn
gezielt entgleisen lassen.
Darum gab es einen Zusammenstoss.
Hier unten bei uns?
- Ja, genau.
Darum hast du das gehört.
- Aha!
Dann gibt er mir
eine seltsame Antwort:
Er wisse es auch nicht genau.
"Ja, es ist ... Geh mal nachsehen!"
Nachher beendeten wir das Gespräch.
Ich konnte nichts sagen,
und er wusste nichts.
In diesem Moment
sassen sie alle im Dunkeln.
Wir wussten nicht, was passiert war.
* Dramatische Musik *
Im Büro wurde es ruhig.
Denn nachdem der Zug
auf das gesperrte Gleis
mit diesen Baumaschinen und Wagen
geleitet worden war,
hatten wir alle ...
... einerseits gehofft,
dass die Hemmschuhe
den Zug noch
entsprechend abzubremsen vermochten.
Wir hatten natürlich gehofft,
dass wir einen Funkspruch
vom Bauzug empfangen würden,
der ungebremst
auf die Baustelle zugefahren war.
Und diesbezüglich
herrschte eine gewisse Anspannung,
wie es weitergehen würde.
Und meine Aufgabe als Dispatcher
war es,
möglichst schnell
Rettungskräfte aufzubieten.
Man ging davon aus, dass es
zu einem Ereignis gekommen war,
kannte aber das Ausmass nicht.
* Telefonklingeln *
Ja, Zimmi.
- Ja?
Guten Morgen!
- Guten Tag!
Es ist nicht gut gegangen.
- Nicht? Was haben wir denn?
Wir hatten einen Dienstextrazug
von Frutigen nach Hondrich.
Ja.
Und kurz vor Reichenbach sagte er,
er habe keine Chance zu bremsen.
Wir wussten nicht,
wie wir reagieren sollten
und leiteten ihn zwischen Gwatt
und Thun zur bestehenden Baustelle.
Ja.
Ja, in jener Woche
hatte ich wieder Pikett.
Und ich kann mich erinnern,
dass ich müde zu Bett ging
und sehr tief schlief.
Und als das Pager-Signal kam,
kam ich aus dem Tiefschlaf.
Ich musste während des Gesprächs
erst aufwachen
und mir dieses Bild
zuerst vorstellen.
Wir haben aktuell die Meldung
von mindestens zwei Verletzten.
Ach nein!
Und es sind Feuerwehr, Sanität,
Polizei und alles aufgeboten.
Aber ... äh ... wer die Verletzten
sind, weiss ich nicht genau.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es derjenige ist,
der auf dem Zug war
oder welche Personen es betrifft.
Ja.
Eben: Man stand dort
und organisierte dann das Ganze.
Man schaute
mit dem Sicherheitswärter zusammen,
wie es weiterging.
Gleis sperren,
Fahrleitungen ausschalten, erden.
Die Feuerwehr kam. Es brannte.
Die Sanität war da.
Wir wussten ja nicht,
was alles geschehen war.
Dann stand man da und ...
Ja, man hat dann ...
Das war's irgendwie.
Wir sind noch da. Wir leben noch.
Sorry!
Wir gingen zum Unfallplatz rüber.
Im ersten Anlauf kamen wir jedoch
nicht über einen 1,6 m Betonklotz,
denn an ihm
fehlte noch eine Metalltreppe.
Wir gingen nachher
zum Nachbarn zurück.
Er war mittlerweile auch bei uns.
Wir holten an der Hauswand eine
Leiter und gingen wieder zurück.
Dann stiegen wir die Leiter hoch
und kamen auf die Schienen.
Dort trafen wir
keine schönen Bilder an.
Hör zu, ich bin beim Unfallplatz.
- Jawohl.
Wenn du etwas haben musst:
Er ist gleich neben meinem Haus.
Du kannst mich zurückrufen.
Wir haben Verletzte.
Und wir haben auch Tote.
- Oh Gott!
Ja, das ist genau bei
der Überführung, Schulstrasse ...
Kannst du das wiederholen?
Schulstrasse?
In Dürrenast.
Die Rettungskräfte
müssen zur Schulstrasse kommen.
Warte, 12, 14, 16 ... Einfach
gleich zur Unterführung der BLS.
Jawohl, das ist gut.
Wir sehen hier Leute, die ...
- Ja, ja, sie sind aufgeboten.
Ich ging als Erstes
Richtung Dürrenast-Unterführung.
Da kam mir ... ähm ...
Peter Luginbühl zuerst entgegen.
Das sehe ich noch vor mir.
Er kam die Treppe von der
ehemaligen Haltestelle hinunter.
Und er hielt mich auf
und bewahrte mich.
Ich sagte zu Jürg,
als ich zurückkam:
"Geh dort nicht hin!
Da liegen zwei Personen am Boden."
"Es ist kein Bild,
das du mitnehmen musst."
Wir vereinbarten, dass wir ...
Wir wussten ja unterdessen, dass
weiter vorne auch noch etwas war.
Ich rückte nachher
zur anderen Unterführung aus,
wo die Wagen auch standen.
Ich hatte zu diesem Zeitpunkt
wenige Informationen.
Aber die Vorstellung,
die ich von Jürg Zimmermann
vernommen hatte, war verheerend.
Ich wusste, dass mich
eine Ausnahmesituation erwartet.
* Dramatische Musik *
Ich sagte zu ihnen, sie sollten
nicht zum Gleis hochgehen,
sondern zu Fuss
über die Strasse zu uns kommen,
damit wir alle zusammen waren.
Man wusste, dass dort
wahrscheinlich zwei Tote lagen.
Ich machte mir Gedanken und ...
Ja, es sind BLS-Mitarbeiter.
Aber ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass es Leute sind, die ich kenne.
* Dramatische Musik *
Fuck!
Ich bekam diese Namen
aus der Einsatzzentrale.
Ich schrieb mir dann
diese Namen auf,
damit ja kein Fehler unterläuft,
wenn man diese Namen
nur mündlich übergibt.
Ich schrieb diese Namen
einzeln untereinander auf
und übergab sie ihm so diskret
wie möglich auf einem Zettel.
Und er berührte mich
in seiner Reaktion.
Der Pfarrer kam zu mir
und zeigte mir den Zettel.
Es war nur ein Notizzettel,
aber ich sehe ihn noch vor mir.
Und ich las diese Namen:
"Henzen" und "Winter".
Damit hatte ich nicht gerechnet.
Ich war nicht darauf vorbereitet.
Ja, ich ging rasch weg,
um für mich zu sein.
Ich habe sicher kurz geweint.
Dann ging ich aber zurück,
um zu funktionieren.
Wir fingen an, mit den
Blaulichtorganisationen aufzubauen.
Mit unseren Fachdiensten.
Natürlich trudelte dann
einer nach dem anderen ein.
* Dramatische Musik *
Meine Frau kam etwa um 4 Uhr.
Ich rief sie an.
Ich wusste nicht,
ob sie diesen Knall gehört hatte.
Wenn ich Nachtschicht hatte,
auch früher,
wenn ich später kommen sollte,
rief ich immer an.
Dann nahmen wir einander
in die Arme.
Es war ein guter Moment.
Ich hatte
keinen Kratzer davongetragen
und konnte meine Liebsten
in die Arme nehmen.
Das ganze Ausmass hatte man
eigentlich noch nicht erfasst.
* Dramatische Musik *
Die dritte Person lag unter diesem
Haufen von Schienenfahrzeugen.
Man wollte diese Person
eigentlich gar nicht rausholen,
weil man Angst hatte,
dass die Wagen runterfallen
und die Retter verletzen könnten,
wenn man dorthin ginge.
Man wollte das Ganze
mit dem Kran einstürzen lassen.
Ich legte mein Veto ein.
Ich sagte, wir würden die Person
zu erreichen versuchen.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass wir es
dieser Person schuldig waren,
sie von der Unfallstelle
wegzubringen
und nicht zuschütten zu lassen.
Es war ein Ostdeutscher.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob er einfach hier arbeitete
und die Familie vielleicht dort
in Ostdeutschland lebte.
Ich glaube,
sie konnten sie gar nicht erreichen,
dass er tot war.
Das fand ich irgendwie ...
... schon noch schlimm.
(Originalton) Ein Zug
rattert durch die finstere Nacht.
Die Bremsen funktionieren nicht.
Es geht
Kilometer um Kilometer bergab,
bis er auf einen anderen Zug
auffährt.
Eine solche Szene
könnte aus einem Horrorfilm stammen.
Letzte Nacht wurde sie Realität. Drei
Männer starben. Geraldine Eicher.
Ineinander verkeilte,
aufeinander geschobene Wagen.
Es passierte
ein ungewöhnlich tragisches Unglück.
Eines der ungewöhnlichsten
der Schweizer Zugsgeschichte.
Und ...
Ja, am Morgen, als ich aufstand ...
Ich weiss auch nicht.
Ich hatte ein negatives Gefühl.
Ich fragte Mama, ob Papa
schon nach Hause gekommen sei.
Am Morgen, als ich aufstand,
war sie in der Küche.
Und ... äh ... ich fragte sie, ob
Papa schon nach Hause gekommen sei.
Und sie sagte: "Nein."
Und sie beruhigte mich immer.
Sie beruhigte mich immer und sagte:
"Er kommt schon.
Du musst dir keine Sorgen machen!"
Aber ich hatte immer
dieses negative Gefühl in mir,
welches ich
nicht so gut beschreiben kann.
Und ich sagte nachher zu ihr,
ich würde das Radio einschalten.
Eigentlich wollte ich hören, wie das
Wetter an jenem Tag werden würde,
denn sie
wollte noch Wäsche aufhängen.
Meine Mama war gerade im Badezimmer,
um zu duschen
und sich die Haare zu machen.
Mitten in der Nacht haben
bei einem BLS-Diesel-Schienentraktor
mit Schotter- und Güterwagen
nicht alle Bremsen funktioniert.
Drei Männer waren auf dem Zug.
Sie hatten an den Weichen gearbeitet.
Als sie merkten, dass sie den Bauzug
nicht mehr bremsen konnten,
schlugen sie Alarm. Nach zig
Kilometern in abschüssigem Gelände
war ihre Fahrt bei Thun zu Ende.
Ich sass vor dem Radio und dachte:
"Ist das jetzt Realität?
Habe ich das richtig gehört?"
"Es ist 8 Uhr.
Mein Vater ist noch nicht zu Hause."
Da kam mir sofort
mein Papa in den Sinn.
Ich sass vor dem Radio und ...
... und dachte:
"Jetzt muss ich es Mama sagen."
Sie föhnte sich gerade die Haare.
Da sagte ich zu ihr ... äh ...
... ich hätte im Radio
etwas ganz Schlimmes gehört.
Sie wusste sofort,
dass mit mir etwas nicht stimmte
und ich nervös war.
Sie fragte: "Was ist denn los?
Was ist denn los?"
Da sagte ich:
"Ich habe im Radio gehört,
dass zwischen Spiez und Thun
ein Bauzugunglück passierte."
"Drei Männer sind tot."
Meine Mama sagte zu mir:
"Wäre mit Papa etwas passiert,
hätten wir das
ja schon lange erfahren."
Zur Bahnlinie
zwischen Thun und Spiez:
Diese bleibt sicher noch bis min-
destens morgen Donnerstag gesperrt.
Die BLS hofft, dass die Strecke
im Verlauf des Tages
wieder eingleisig befahrbar ist.
Als ich am Morgen zu mir kam,
sah ich,
dass ich
17 unbeantwortete Anrufe hatte.
Die Leute wollten etwas von mir.
Viele Kollegen und Bekannte wussten,
dass ich schon seit längerer Zeit
dort arbeitete.
Und das beeindruckte mich,
dass manchmal halt doch jemand
an einen denkt.
Aber es hätte auch mich
erwischen können.
Ja, dann wäre ich
auch irgendwie krausi-mausi
dort in diesem Zeug gewesen,
nehme ich an. Also unerkenntlich.
Weil ich es nicht glaubte.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass so etwas passieren kann,
dass dieses Zeug abgeht,
ohne dass es gebremst wird.
Nachher sagte ich zu ihr:
"Aber ruf Papa mal aufs Handy an!"
Da sagte sie:
"Er mag es nicht so sehr,
wenn man ihn bei der Arbeit anruft."
Da sagte ich zu ihr:
"Du musst ihm sagen,
dass ich mir grosse Sorgen mache
und wir nur wissen wollten,
ob alles in Ordnung sei."
Dann rief sie ihn aufs Handy an.
Da ging natürlich niemand ran.
Und sie meinte nur,
er rufe sicher zurück.
Ich bekam eigentlich keinen Anruf.
Es ist ja klar: Die wollten mich
damit nicht belasten.
Wir gingen am Morgen nach der
Schicht mit dem Bus wieder zurück.
Aber mich hat ...
Ich hatte den Eindruck,
bei den Vorarbeitern
und Vorgesetzten
herrschte eine gedrückte Stimmung.
Ich nehme an,
weil sie es mitbekommen hatten.
Dann gingen wir
nach der Nachtschicht nach Hause.
Wir schliefen.
Meine Partnerin sagte am Mittag,
ihre Schwester habe angerufen.
Es war schon 8.15 Uhr oder 8.30 Uhr.
Dann sagte ich zu ihr:
"Jetzt musst du mal
nach Goppenstein telefonieren!"
"Die wissen ja sicher mehr darüber,
was in dieser Nacht passiert ist."
Dann rief meine Mama
nach Goppenstein an.
Der stellvertretende Bahnmeister
nahm den Anruf entgegen.
Man fragte sie einfach,
ob sie zu Hause sei.
Mama sagte Ja.
Dann begann sie zu weinen.
Sie war traurig und legte auf.
Dann fing sie richtig zu weinen an.
Ich sagte:
"Mein Vater ist tot, oder?"
Sie sagte, sie wüssten es nicht,
aber wir müssten hier zu Hause
warten, bis jemand vorbeikäme.
* Dramatische Musik *
Ich kann mich gut daran erinnern,
dass die Frauen der verstorbenen
Männer immer wieder versuchten,
auf deren Handy anzurufen.
Und - das tut mir so leid
für die Angehörigen -
da gab es enorme Verzögerungen.
Man musste zuerst
mit der Identifikation sicher sein:
Waren es wirklich diese drei Männer?
Nicht, dass eine Fehlinformation
verbreitet wurde.
Und das Kantonsübergreifende
machte es nicht einfach.
Da vergingen Stunden, bis man die
Trauerfamilien direkt kontaktierte.
Es war so gegen 10.45 Uhr, 11 Uhr.
Ein Polizist der
Kantonspolizei Wallis kam vorbei -
eben zusammen
mit dem Bahnmeister Stellvertreter.
Er musste uns eigentlich
nicht viel sagen.
Ja, es war
ein schlimmer, schlimmer Moment.
* Dramatische Musik *
Geht's?
Nach Feierabend
fuhr ich mit dem Fahrrad nach Hause.
Ich fand eigentlich,
weil ich sehr lange gearbeitet hatte
und es anstrengend war,
relativ schnell Schlaf.
Ich bin aber bereits ...
... gegen 11 Uhr wieder aufgewacht.
Da bekam ich in den Nachrichten
erst das ganze Ausmass mit.
Es passierte um 3.20 Uhr.
Eine knappe halbe Stunde später
steigt Rauch
von der Unfallstelle auf.
Im Minutentakt
trifft Verstärkung der Feuerwehr ein.
Die Rettungskräfte
treffen auf ein Chaos.
Züge und Wagen liegen übereinander.
Und da vernahm ich natürlich auch,
dass es Opfer gab.
Und ... das ist ... äh ...
... das gewesen, was man am liebsten
nicht gehört hätte.
Und ich denke,
das sind bei mir die Gedanken,
die mich am meisten beschäftigten.
Eben: Was ...
Was ist mit diesen Hinterbliebenen?
Die Leute werden informiert,
dass ihre Ehemänner, ihre Väter,
nicht mehr nach Hause kommen.
Und das ist das,
was ... was extrem wehtat.
Und es tut immer noch weh.
* Dramatische Musik *
Ich habe so etwas noch nie gesehen.
Die Wagen waren
wirklich meterhoch aufeinander.
Und man wusste eigentlich gar nicht,
warum das so passiert war.
Damit wir das ganze Ausmass
des Schadens überblicken konnten,
machten wir einen Helikopterflug und
sahen uns den Schaden von oben an.
* Dramatische Musik *
In Dürrenast standen zwei Wagen.
Der Bauzug
fuhr zuerst in diese Wagen.
Der Bauzug schob diese 500 m weiter
zur nächsten Baustelle.
Dort standen sechs Wagen,
die auch gebremst waren.
Und der Zug prallte dort auf.
Die meisten Wagen entgleisten.
Man kann dem Untersuchungsbericht
der SUST entnehmen,
dass der Bauzug beim ersten Aufprall
noch 89 km/h schnell war.
Und beim zweiten Aufprall,
also 500 m weiter vorne
mit zwei geschobenen Wagen,
war er noch 80 km/h schnell.
* Dramatische Musik *
Um den Mittag herum ...
... ging ich nach Hause,
um zu schlafen.
Das ging natürlich nicht.
Theoretisch
sollte man ja schlafen können,
wenn man richtig müde ist.
Aber das war kein Schlafen.
Die Bilder, die ganze Sache
waren allgegenwärtig.
Und nachher - um 16 Uhr, 16.30 Uhr -
riefen sie von der Firma an.
Das Fernsehen habe gefragt, ob ich
in Dürrenast ein Interview gäbe.
Nachher fuhr ich dorthin.
Man machte das Interview.
Den ganzen Tag wurde die Unfallstelle
heute geräumt und untersucht.
Viele der Rettungskräfte und Arbeiter
sind seit Stunden auf den Beinen.
Michael Krayenbühl
kommt zurück an die Unfallstelle.
Letzte Nacht arbeitete er hier
zusammen mit seinen acht Kollegen
auf der Baustelle in Dürrenast.
Wir waren etwa 30 m im Feld.
Man hörte es hier
in Dürrenast rumpeln.
Dann kam so ein Feuerregen
hier um das gelbe Haus herum.
60 bis 80 km/h schätzungsweise.
In der Nacht ist es schwierig.
Dann knallte es hier beim Bauzug.
Die Wagen bäumten sich auf.
Die Eisenträger dort drin
flogen wie Mikado-Stäbchen herum.
Was wirklich mit dem Zug passierte,
wird genau untersucht.
Die betroffenen Arbeiter
und die Angehörigen der drei Toten
werden psychologisch betreut.
Ich habe sie ja nicht gekannt,
aber sie waren greifbar da.
Und da tauchte bei mir
schon auch die Frage auf,
warum so etwas passiert
und man selber Glück hatte.
In Dürrenast,
wo dieses Unglück passierte,
ist jetzt Sabine Dahinden
mit dem BLS-Direktor Mathias Tromp.
Ja, und Mathias Tromp ist seit mehr
als 15 Stunden auf den Beinen.
Und ich habe das Gefühl,
es geht Ihnen sehr nahe.
Ja, wir von der BLS
sind alle betroffen.
Drei Mitarbeiter,
drei Kollegen zu verlieren -
zwei aus der eigenen Firma
und einen dritten,
der uns in der Nacht half -,
tut weh.
Das bewegt.
Ich bedauere das ausserordentlich.
Und ich möchte allen, die betroffen
sind, mein Beileid ausdrücken,
v.a. den drei Familien.
Drei Familienväter sind heute
von uns gegangen. Das tut weh.
* Dramatische Musik *
Am Anfang
nahm ich es noch nicht so wahr.
Erst später, all die Jahre,
wenn man manchmal
an diesen 17. Mai denkt,
eine Flasche Wein öffnet,
denkt man,
dass man Schwein gehabt hat.
Oder an Weihnachten,
wenn ich eine Kerze anzünde,
macht mich das schon betroffen.
Ich habe die beiden Lokführer
gekannt.
Sie waren auch im Lötschberg
bei der Huckepack-Absenkung.
Und Klaus sagte oft,
er habe die Prüfung nicht
und könne nicht
so viel Tonnage anhängen.
Ich kann mir heute
noch nicht vorstellen,
dass das in jener Nacht
passieren konnte.
Wenn man nicht so entschieden hätte:
Hätte es mehr Opfer gegeben?
Das ist Spekulation.
Das können wir nie sagen.
Die Frage tauchte immer auf,
wieso man den Zug
nicht ins Simmental fahren liess.
Dort waren auch Bauarbeiten.
Dort gibt es unbewachte Bahn-
übergänge. Man hoffte einfach, dass,
wenn man den Zug
möglichst geradeaus fahren lässt,
er zum Stillstand kommen würde.
Aber man stellte fest,
dass es besser ist, ihn auf
ein Hindernis auffahren zu lassen.
Diejenigen,
die das entscheiden mussten,
hätte ich nicht sein wollen -
in dieser relativ kurzen Zeit.
Ich bin mir eigentlich auch bewusst,
dass mit diesen beiden
Fahrdienstleitern zusammen ...
... eigentlich alle Varianten
durchgespielt werden konnten:
Es gab
einfach nur schlechte Varianten.
Aber wir hatten
von diesen schlechten
vielleicht noch die beste erwischt.
Ich weiss, dass die Fahrdienstleiter
Schuldgefühle hatten.
Die Auswirkungen ihres Entscheides
waren für sie verheerend.
Sie haben ...
... eigentlich sich selber ...
... zur Rechenschaft gezogen.
Man musste ihnen beweisen,
dass sie
keinen Fehler gemacht hatten.
Es beschäftigte sie sehr.
Aus meiner Sicht
wurden die drei Fahrdienstleiter
Opfer einer unglaublichen Tragödie.
Im Untersuchungsbericht
wird festgehalten,
dass zwischen der Lokomotive
und dem ersten Wagen in der Brems-
leitung ein Hahn geschlossen war.
Es konnte also keine Luft
durch diese Leitung hindurch -
weder in die eine
noch in die andere Richtung.
D.h., man konnte die Bremsen
dieser Wagen nicht betätigen
und auch nicht lösen.
Der Untersuchungsbericht ...
... lässt aus meiner Sicht
sehr viele Fragen offen.
Offen bleibt eigentlich,
was genau in Frutigen
in diesen zwei Stunden passiert war
und was genau diese ...
... Störungsphänomene waren,
dass sie den Wagen ausrangierten.
Warum sie nachher
offensichtlich keine richtige
Bremsprobe machten -
sie können sie nicht gemacht haben,
sonst wäre der Hahn
nicht geschlossen gewesen -,
das bleibt im Dunkeln.
Eine Zeit lang
spielte ich auch mit dem Gedanken -
ein paar Monate später -,
ob ich mit den Angehörigen
in Kontakt treten sollte.
Aber je mehr Zeit verging,
desto weniger war ich der Meinung,
dass das gut wäre.
Ich habe es nicht gemacht.
Ich habe heute noch das Gefühl,
dass die Angehörigen ...
... das Gefühl hatten,
wir seien schuld.
Das könnte ich ihnen
auch nicht übel nehmen.
Ich bin zwar betroffen,
aber nicht das Opfer.
Das sind die Verstorbenen,
die Angehörigen.
Die Gedanken an sie
kommen immer wieder.
Jeder von uns
hätte dort vorne drauf sein können.
Ihnen war ein Fehler unterlaufen.
Normalerweise
kann man Fehler machen,
aber da war es verheerend.
Wir wohnten an der Alpenstrasse.
Diese liegt schätzungsweise
2 km vom Unglücksort entfernt.
Es gab für uns einen Unterbruch
von etwa 14 Tagen.
In dieser Zeit war man ja zu Hause.
Wir haben Sachen repariert.
Aber wir
hatten eigentlich keinen Einsatz.
Ich hörte nachts
jeden Zug vorbeifahren.
Da fahren ja ziemlich
viele Züge durch, auch Güterzüge.
Auch bei geschlossenem Fenster
hörte ich sie.
Da sagte ich zu mir,
dass das Ganze keinen Sinn macht.
* Düstere Musik *
Nachher rief ich
den Care-Team-Chef an und sagte ihm,
dass ich mich nicht wohlfühle.
Dann sagte er,
sie könnten nichts machen.
Ich solle zum Hausarzt gehen.
Dann ging ich zu meinem Hausarzt
und erklärte ihm alles.
Er meinte, es mache keinen Sinn,
wenn ich dorthin gehe.
Er empfahl mir eine Psychiaterin.
Dann therapierte man das, sagt man
vielleicht - oder behandelt.
Ich dachte, ich sei ein harter Kerl.
Ich bräuchte keine Unterstützung.
Aber im Nachhinein bereue ich es,
dass ich mich nicht damit befasste
und mir helfen liess.
Ich hatte lange
mit mir selbst zu kämpfen.
Ich habe mich eben auch ...
Es wurde auch nie aufgetragen,
dass man Hilfe haben könnte.
Im Nachhinein muss man sagen,
es würde einem wohl besser gehen.
Das sei ein "Postneuro-
depressivtrauma", sagten sie.
Ich wusste nicht ganz genau,
was das sein könnte,
aber sie umschrieben es wie folgt:
Wenn man einen Kilometer
davon entfernt gewesen wäre,
hätte einem das nichts ausgemacht.
Aber da man so nahe war
und fast unter den Zug geraten wäre,
kann das etwas auslösen.
Nachher behandelte man das
in zehn Sitzungen oder so.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Dreiklanghorn *
Ich fuhr mit Papa oft
auf den Sanetschpass.
Und das hatte auch
mit der Zeit zu tun,
in der Papa im Militär war,
also in der RS.
Damals lernte er meine Mama kennen.
Und im Militär war er eine oder
drei Wochen hier oben, glaube ich.
Und ja, Mama
schrieb ihm jeden Tag einen Brief.
Und immer, wenn das Postauto kam -
tatütata -
kam auch der Brief.
Das erzählte er immer voller Freude.
Das sei immer ganz schön gewesen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Wir gingen oft auf den Sanetschpass,
weil Papa hier einfach
schöne Erinnerungen hatte.
Er kam mit mir hier hinauf.
Ich bin auch ein Naturmensch.
Hier gibt es viele schöne Blumen.
Das ist immer noch ein Ort,
an den ich sehr oft hingehe.
Auch wenn Papa nicht mehr da ist -
es tut mir richtig gut,
wenn ich im Sommer
auf diese Alp gehen kann.
"Das schönste Denkmal,
das ein Mensch bekommen kann,
steht in den Herzen
seiner Mitmenschen."
"Albert Schweizer".
"In Erinnerung an das tragische
Eisenbahnunglück vom 17. Mai 2006".
"Otto Henzen, Lokführer BLS AG".
"Niklaus Winter, Lokführer BLS AG".
"Lutz Hanath,
Mitarbeiter Vanoli AG".
"Die BLS AG".
"Du musstest so unerwartet
von uns gehen."
"Du hattest nicht viel Zeit,
dich noch einmal umzudrehen."
"Doch deine Liebe
ist bei uns geblieben."
"So lebst du in uns weiter,
weil wir dich lieben."